is brought to you by Adam and eve.com
who wants better sex and who wants to
start having better sex immediately um
hello everyone the best way to get
started is to go to Adam and eve.com
right yeah cuz I'm like how do you do it
you know what I'm saying and then you're
just like go to Adam and eve.com okay
that makes sense Adam and Eve is
offering 50% off just about any item
plus free shipping which includes Rush
processing more than that Adam and Eve
wants to make your life easy they offer
discret shipping as your privacy is a
priority plus 100% free shipping with
Rush processing on your entire order all
right what if you buy really expensive
stuff and how you spend so much money
doesn't matter how much you spend or
what you buy all will be packaged and
sent discretly for free and fast wa
don't wait better sex is just a click
away so one item that's 50% off one item
one item free shipping but not free Rush
R processing with free Rush processing
it is bring more pleasure and
satisfaction into your bedroom just go
to Adam and eve.com and select any one
item it could be an adventurous new toy
or anything anything anything you desire
just enter offer code Lifeline at
checkout that's Lifeline l i f l i n
Adam andeve.com this is an exclusive off
offer specific to this podcast so if
you're a homey to this podcast be sure
to use this code Lifeline to get your
discount 100% free shipping and get it
fast with Rush processing code lifeline
are you or are you not a little wussy
baby man right yeah it's honestly comes
down to it's as simple as that you're a
little Wy baby man diap a little wussy
baby man and you need diapers
yep
Runk hello
hello
hello oh and shark by
ready with his dude my special hey how
about that look at that the special
official gr die merch I didn't even see
it until right now but my special's out
grow or die that's nice that's really
nice thanks dude you can get this on
chris.com but you can also get the
special on chris.com you directed it you
did and uh grow or die it is uh awesome
and uh I appreciate you guys who already
bought it and you can go get it now
chris.com you can also uh sign up for
this patreon patreon.com Lifeline lxury
it's Sunday November 12th Sundays are
for Lifeline but Lifeline luxury is also
Sunday's our for Lifeline luxury so go
get that uh I'm on tour go to uh I got
uh Fort no wait no that'll be done uh
Richmond Baltimore Trenton Philadelphia
and reading and Oxnard California and
Matt has some news I got a new podcast
coming out real soon I got 10 or maybe
even 12 in the can already w got some
amaz yeah man uh we want to hear your
stories we want to hear your crazy
stories I am the host you will tell me
your story we got like I said a bunch in
the can some amazing episodes already
can't wait to record more if you want to
be a guest on the show you got some kind
of crazy story you want to share with
the world go submit yourself at the
privat docomo the privat
gmail.com or find us on Instagram Tik
Tok or
YouTube I mean drowning yeah that's
what's up if you have a question go down
to the link uh watch lifeline.com or 101
advice s with Matt at mata.com anyway
dude Lifeline merch Lifeline merch.com
we got a lot of stuff going on but uh
it's all good my babies and we are here
at a lifeline and uh so do you remember
the pecking order of glasses that was
established yeah well I remember that we
talked about I don't actually remember
the I'm not ask I'm not going to quiz
you there's another pair of glasses and
it's on my face and they're green these
are green and I wore it because I'm
wearing a green sweatsuit that's pretty
that's pretty cool sock what kind of
sweatsuit is that do you know uh lean is
it new or vintage uh it's new letan that
makes me actually hate French people the
way you do that it's from letin so those
are green glasses they're green green
green green green green but you're
wearing green
sunglasses and I want them cuz they
grain and I like to wear all one color
when it's possible uhhuh well your
monochromatic matte yeah um well okay
that's cool man I got green too you got
green it's the Green episode and look at
that that's green too whoa look at this
what the heck um well that uh nice
hoodie though for real those are really
cool those those grower diey hoodies I
had I honestly had not even seen them
until yeah it's a old take on the skater
die [__] you remember skater die grower
die what nice yeah
mad so great great a guy a guy who used
to uh wear that stuff had sex with his
uh girlfriend you know back in way back
oh yeah that's great cool yeah love
thinking about that wonder what Chad's
up to um so uh no there's actually a lot
of cool grower die merch I go hard with
the merch you know I love I like doing
it you love
merchesi do I love
merchesi deep cut joke sorry I made it
is that why Anthony laugh sorry I made
it yeah he's a dork too just like me
what is it on like Wolverine issue5
something no Walter merch is like a very
fam famous Walter merch is introduced uh
dead dead Deadpool's uh origin story of
w Deadpool no Apocalypse Now more like
that you know so Anthony laughs so it's
probably about you know the uh Batman
Lego terrifier Lego Batman or whatever
Lego Batman dude Anthony loves the Lego
movies especially so much popcorn when
he goes yeah dude gets two and acts like
he's also getting another tub for
someone else but he's just getting both
popcorns for himself and also saw it
twice in the theater and the second time
he saw it he didn't admit that he
already saw it to whoever he went with
right he's like yeah no we should go see
it sure um right right right yeah he did
that I'll see I'll see it and then
pretended like we he he predicted aart
and predicted like he predicted
aart you know what's going to happen
here and it does it and like I just [__]
I just know it I know it I just know the
Lego movies yeah stripping
stripping at that you got green on under
there too man see it's so hot it's so
weird how it's so blisteringly hot and
it's called outside which is what's
interesting it's called outside yeah so
anyway um I'm feeling good you feeling
good I feel good shoulder pain no back
pain that's it okay well that was I have
shoulder pain why no neck pain little
bit of neck pain no back pain dude for
the first time in my
life I have well no no for like past six
years okay I have no lower back pain
what happened oh there's a fly here
that's cool I don't know dude I don't
know what happened I guess I just
started working out better and and and
different and and my core or something I
started doing vops hanging v-ups yeah
hanging with the V you know bring the
legs all the way up to the face kiss
kiss your kiss your toes I'm interested
um and uh and I have shoulder pain so
that's cool and the reason why I have
shoulder pain is I've now trans I trans
I've transcended to the I don't get hurt
doing physical activity anymore I get
hurt just being a dad uh my son Calvin I
was driving and he said dad I I dropped
my thing so I went to grab
it oh
pain 3
weeks insurmountable did it hurt right
away when you did it oh yeah you should
have as a you should be a better dad and
what you should do as dad say I life is
hard you can't reach it tough ters I
don't care tough ters good luck getting
it on your own let's see you try to do
that my son understands half of those
words actually you know what's crazy
yeah that's not true no my son I have a
joke on my special about how he's not
that good at talking but he's good for
his age dude the other he said um no I
would rather have that one uhhuh and I'm
like who the who thought you rather yeah
yeah what about this one as well he'll
say I'm like what are you who what are
you watching like British cooking shows
yeah it's unbelievable dude I bet he is
everyone watches those shows I can't
stand it dude here we are at you know
Manchester B off everyone watches the
British Bake Off show whatever it's
called and every like oh the hosts are
so funny and entertaining it's like no
they're not dude by the way Britain has
the worst Food yeah but sweet it's about
sweets oh and they have good sweets I
guess yeah today we're learning we're
going to see who can who can make a
better tomato and beans yeah for
breakfast of course you nilly wits
you're not going to eat that any
anywhere past 9:00 a.m. beans and a
tomato and whipped cream nilly wits you
know nilly wit here we go you nlyt
imagine eating beans and a tomato at at
past 800 a.m. are you crazy what no you
nlyt all right here we go we've got
Nigel Nigel worst and and uh and uh
what's the well it's not Nigel Nigel
worst so what you asking me about now
you know what's the the lady Hollywood
who Paul Hollywood let me tell you about
Paul Hollywood he's one of the hosts
Paul
Hollywood
sucks I mean but he has the greatest
name of all time great that's not his
real last name dude dude why not that's
my last
name look him up I don't even know who
that Hollywood I guarantee he's a guy
with silver hair Paul Hollywood oh well
there we go look at him I'm right he
obviously had silver hair he doesn't
suck come on look at him no he doesn't
suck you're right take it back who's the
other guy though the other guy does suck
n n Fielding or whatever all right I'm
going to get thrashed for this cuz
people love that guy dude this guy I've
never he's never made me laugh yet
people love this guy he's fine but look
at his
hat yeah the Hat it's okay no the Hat
what hat that one oh that's not good but
yeah no he's fine he's just like I I
don't I don't know anything about these
guys so I've never seen there's a woman
that hosted two right the three there's
three yeah
yeah um it's so so so popular and I've
been made so people like more than one
person has been like you got to let's
watch that let's watch that what what is
it called the Great British Bake Off yes
and I'm just like actually the woman is
my favorite one that's right I forgot a
she's like the she gets mean and it's
fun is that the guy from that show the
long hair guy so big yeah the the mighty
Bo yeah people love that I the other guy
from The Mighty bush is hilarious to me
I don't like this guy that much I don't
know it's probably because I've seen
this too much and I just I'm not I've
never seen competition cooking shows
never seen you don't know what the
mighty bu is even I know what it is I've
never seen it yeah the mighty bush is
like a really really really famous
popular English from a long time ago
though it's pretty it was like to me my
recollection is it's one of those things
that became viral before things became
viral yeah it was it was like as right
what like in the mid off yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah wasn't there something where
he was on like a boat in a lake or
something this the old Greg thing yeah
isn't that what that is the old Greg
thing people love that old Greg thing I
don't know what old Greg is I saw like a
clip of it or
something yeah yeah yeah that that thing
was very very viral people thought it
was so funny and I watched like 10
seconds of it and I was like I think I'm
just not British I forget the other
guy's name but he's funny people love it
though yeah people love it British
people are are just they're on a
different like wavelength though
sometimes yeah not a way people assume
because they also speak English that
like they're really A Lot Like Us nope
they're not a lot like us like every
single yeah British person will say
Faulty Towers is like the all-time best
thing have have either of you guys ever
watched Faulty Towers Faulty Towers I
watch it like this oh
really really I like absolutely fabulous
imagine watching something like that
we're going to piss British people off
today because they're eating beans and a
tomato a know right wow if you're
listening to the podcast before at you
are otherwise you're being a nilly w
ailly w yeah why would you eat beans in
a tomato pass half off seven what or
really why would you eat beans in a
tomato at all well they do that in
British remember when we were in London
cuz they have no other food remember
when we were in London and we were going
we were like let's go get some breakfast
we got up early because we were jet
lagged we got up early went and we were
like I'll get oh they only have beans
and tomato beans and you were like well
we were like we were like I'll get a
tomato they're like you want beans on
the side we're like on the side like a
Tomato's the main part of the it was
though what else was there it was like a
one of the the one of the main things
was like a [__] uh you know a sausage
thing that was it was like plastic
they'll do links yeah they do sausage L
and they do fish right fish and chips is
their thing for breakfast yeah fish for
breakfast dude they they got limited
options dude they why though it's a
place yeah it's true you can just get so
true also they're the they're Britain
like they they I know it's great
there now it's hard to get stuff in
Britain because of brexit though but
back then yeah there was no excuse no
excuse brexit stage left you know what
they say mhm brexit
what what what did you say so [__]
stupid I didn't even hear what you said
he said brexit stage
left oh wow wow wow wow
wow oh man laughed wow you guys all suck
cuz it's so stupid dud I laughed cuz you
guys left I have no idea what a follower
a
follower dude an absolute follower dude
brexit stage right all right wow you
didn't even hear it and just laughed
like a
dumbo just heard laughter in start of
going that's what my that's what Calvin
does dude that's also like a it's
Butthead you're
butthead you know you're just Butthead
dude no man you almost spit out your
drink it was
funny wait wait hold on a child a child
a child Works spit out your drink who
did did you spit out your you at that
you laugh at me laughing not the brexit
stage left joke Oh you mean oh wait
you're realizing the thing he said a
whole minute ago no he said I laughed
and I didn't even hear it and then no I
I no I said I don't even know what the
hell you're talking about yeah right
right right like I don't get the joke so
and you laughed at it he laughed at it
yes but I laughed at you laughing that's
not what he said dude doesn't matter
what he said it but this is goes back to
what we were saying earlier I'm right
about this I am right about this dude he
said hold dude this is am I autistic he
said well yeah he said that's fine
though but you're this right what's
right cuz he said I laughed and I don't
even know what what did what was it I
said I laughed and I don't even get the
joke I laughed I don't get the joke yeah
I thought he said I laughed I don't know
what you said okay so I'm supposed to
know that he laughed at me laughing
that's not what he said a minute ago he
initially
clear no dude it was very clear based on
what he said that he was laughing just
because other people laughed which is a
verion I don't remember the exact words
but what he said was I'm laughing
because other people laughed that's why
I said follower in the first place the
other one that happened before the show
was more clear and I was more right
about that one no you were wrong about
that too you got to tell if you're going
to talk going to Mako said Chris said
what's the answer to sell me this pen
mhm and I said what but what just to
insert real quick just to be clear CU I
knew exactly what he meant but go ahead
but I said that's not a question and
then you said yeah but you know how on
Wolf of Wall Street Jordan bord makes a
guy sell him your pen and I said yeah no
I and you said so you know what he means
no I don't know what he means at the end
of the movie Yes got out of that one he
goes around at his seminar and some so
then what the [__] are you confused
about he said what's the answer to sell
he's going around from guy shut up he's
going around from guy to guy getting
asking them to do it right the right way
and then with person doesn't know the
person doesn't get it the person doesn't
get it and then shut the [__] up then if
you know because that's not I when he
says what's the answer to some of this
pen I
think here's why you're done yeah I know
I know and that's okay to think that but
it's also not okay to think to not think
more things after that that's how we
make sense of the world somebody says
something and you think beyond the
literal meaning of every word one at a
time your word is your bond dude your
word is your bond and if you're not
saying the correct because here you know
what you know what it truly is actually
what I'm realizing it
I'm I'm it's an insecure thing because I
think there's something that he knows
that I don't know that I should
understand so what are you talking about
like is there an answer to it that I'm
not privy to yeah there is there is a
response that he's looking for that is
correct that is what he meant that's
what he was asking about Jordan Bufford
is looking for a speci to I'm at Target
that's that's not something but Jordan
Belford specifically Jord bord said I'm
at Target there's an answer to it it's
not asking you [__] [__] let's go to
the [__] lifelines dude everyone
listening absolutely knows I'm right but
I don't think they do dude they
absolutely do they all know what's
implied by that question if they know
who Jordan bord is is if they know what
sum of this pen is bro that's and I
think you do too which is even more
annoying no I know what do you think
Jord hold on hold on what do you think
Jordan bford is doing what do you think
he's looking for when he says some me
this pen to and and each person that he
does it to tries to sell him this pen
and Jordan buford's like no that's wrong
goes to the next one how would you sell
me this
pen what do you what does that mean how
would you sell me this pen that what's
the answer to how you would sell me this
pen yeah that's the same thing he's
saying just different the answer to sell
me this Penny oh my god dude like as if
semantics is the problem it's just like
that's what I'm saying every you know
you know you you know so what is the
answer then we didn't know that's why we
were all talking about it we didn't
remember if there's an answer then what
is it we don't know but it's out there
that's why we
asked we don't know we wouldn't have
asked if we knew we would have just said
hey you know how Jordan buffer says some
of this pen this is what he's looking
for
now I'm way more hot than it already was
it was already hot hot it's so hot okay
all right whatever we know where each
person stands hey chis my name is Victor
I am from Serbia added a big big fan uh
I tried to show your Clips to my Serbian
friends all the time but they never
understand never laugh because of the
language barrier so I just usually end
up watching them watching the clip just
like that's cool though you're still
trying waiting checking if they like it
so insecure but I do have a question
watching TV shows and movies about uh
Mafia there's always this mafia boss who
speaks in a really low volume that I
understand that's a dominance thing but
they say the vaguest [__] and the people
act as if they understood what they said
now that could get really confusing in a
real life situation but in a movie it
would look like a guy begging for his
life please please save me and the mafia
boss would be like the spars and the cat
and they would be like thank you thank
you and I'm like no you didn't hear him
you didn't understand him so is it lazy
writing like what is your take on it
thank you guys so so much AG you two
would get along great yeah this guy
would agree with me the answer though is
obvious what it's it's implied in any
mafia movie there there are they their
own group with their own language the
mafia boss doesn't say things outright
because he doesn't want to have to have
it in any way be able to come back
around him the whole point of being
brought up slowly in the mob through the
ranks is you you learn what things mean
within your group of people yeah and so
the mob boss isn't going to go around
being like kill him y on Friday thank
you he's going to say take care of him
before the weekend whatever the [__] it
is you know exactly which is why in the
real world and not in mafia movies there
is no answer to sell me this pen oh my
God and thank you very much well worst
lawyer in history and that your honor is
where I arrest my case yeah uh well that
I just answered his question that that
that's not that still not good writing
though because let's face it there's
been enough movies about Mafia I frankly
don't think so you know you don't think
so you should see no I think 50 to 60%
of movies should be about
mster yeah I mean I do like a lot of
mafia movies but that yeah I think they
should insert M Mobsters into every into
into 50 to 60% of movies I don't think
they should make I think but like Avatar
would be cool if like they were like
right flying by and go like you know you
gotta you gotta connect the the the dog
to the [__] guy in there and then
they're connecting and then they flying
around and that's the person right oh so
you okay you would like Mafia people in
the world of every movie not just like
adding separate scenes of Mafia bosses
being like take care of the thing
actually that would be really funny if
they just cut to two Mobsters talking
about avatars I would I would yeah
that's a good idea see we we build on it
you know and it's like to be like ah you
ever see the [__] blue guys walking
around and then they got a [__] you
know get the [__] out of here with blue
guys happens and then Cuts back
to
[Music]
weather
flly yeah dude in romantic comedies with
Dyan McDermot you know yeah I do hey
[__] yeah you see they got married
they did no get the [__] out of here
and okay well aveng
Avengers that guy's big and [__]
green you know yeah people wouldn't even
notice in The Avengers you
know it wouldn't you're right all right
so hi Chris and Matt massive fan I have
a question so I like to work out that
sounds annoying but I do and sometimes
let's say I'm on a trip with people and
I'll get up earlier than everyone else
to out before the day activities that's
crazy and sometimes I get comments like
oh my God you're crazy
or don't you want to just sleep in you
just miss one
day and it's so annoying and I need a qu
response that's funny and witty to just
like snap at them y so let me know I'm a
massive fan I Saw You Laugh Factory a
couple months ago awesome you're so
hilarious and Matt thank you for keeping
Chris and
check I think that that is extremely
annoying and I think that it should be I
don't know exactly what it should be but
it should be something about how you
don't tell them what to do just because
yeah it's the way you do a thing like
that's so annoying CU it's like what why
do you care I'm working out you sleep in
all you want cuz they wish they did you
think so yeah definitely everyone wishes
they were healthier you know that's such
an extreme way to show them your abs
uhhuh go like this here's why and then
go like this a or or say you're lucky I
don't make you do it with me what you
want you want to shut the [__] up about
it and let me do
it or I'll wake wake up you do burpees I
mean dude that's so annoying yeah you
should
uh also just you're you
know people are lazy slobs and Ah that's
really annoying [__] I don't know what
to tell you besides maybe get new
friends yeah cuz here's the here's the
other thing that's super annoying when
somebody's just like yeah why don't you
come work out with me like what that's
your version of it and you don't do that
right yeah well I mean unless you do but
it's like dude you know what just yeah
say here's what you should say do you
realize when someone does that say do
you realize how that annoying that is
that's as annoying as me hounding you
and trying to force you to come work out
with me obviously you don't want to do
that and obviously I don't want to make
you do that so why do you want to make
me do your thing I would do that I would
do that that that that's the Tit for Tat
that's that's what they deserve if they
say it to you and you've already said it
like yeah answered it and they do it
again then you wake them up next time
you work out yeah yeah if you're on a
trip yeah dude I F I don't wake up early
in the morning but you know it when I I
was my last trip I went on I worked out
I dude I love it man it's awesome I
don't bug anybody about it yeah that's
the thing if you're not bugging anybody
why are they bugging you nobody even do
it after the trip like after they're
back home and your back home at 7:00
a.m. call
them every day and say hey come work out
with me why don't you want to work out
with me I mean so so extreme you know
outside of their apartment it is weird
that people uh work get up man people
get I they get what say the thing
otherwise no one knows what you're
saying I'm processing I cannot imagine
waking up earlier than I need to so I
can get a workout in I I I if I had a 9
to5 I guess I would have to try and do
that because I have kids and I don't
want to not see my kids before they go
to sleep yeah that's definitely I guess
that's it but dude some people are just
single with no kids yeah but you know
what that's about they want to get they
want to wake up and get it over with and
it's like if it's part of your routine
you roll out of bed and get it done then
you feel good the rest of the day you're
not like I got to fit in a workout yes
but some of those people still go to
sleep at like midnight
yeah I don't understand I need a minimum
of 9 hours of sleep a night yeah you're
such a dude I don't I if if I got 9
hours I would be so [__] the whole day
I would just be so groggy what bro I
don't know I really would be yeah how
much you get six sometimes a little less
and I feel good better anything over
seven and I'll have like a headache
that's not good dude you're going to die
early
well I I mean I don't know what to say
yeah you are supposed to get it
fluctuates from person to person
obviously but you're supposed to get at
least seven yeah dude if I can get 11 oh
my God I wake up and it's dope bro I
wake up and it's like bro I think I like
[__] I just feel like I'm on a
different planet you feel good if you
get 11 hours of sleep oh yeah bro I mean
came absolutely so good like not good so
good explain that that makes that
doesn't even really make sense to me
okay I feel like
I've recharged
like completely full
100%
recharged I can open any apps in my body
I'm just ready to go are you a human I'm
an
iPhone uh I'm the iPhone 15 yeah I mean
that makes sense that's what literally
happened you
recharged um I got the new iPhone okay
well that's boring we're not going to
talk about that okay let's didn't up yet
I got three days ago that's how crazy I
am oh dude that's good I like that you
know why cuz it makes him he just
shivered in his boots why does he hate
that he's just the least dude honestly
I've bought things at my house that he
does not live at right he'll come over
see a box somewhere and not like dude
like this for real like you're talking
to me you're me the box is over there
you'll be talking saying what's going on
what's going on
yeah uhhuh that's because he's like it's
like it's like boil a [__] heroin
addict and like the fix is over like
over there and he just wants get it over
with and get in his body open a box what
the fix is opening a box yeah the fix is
and and then setting it up though it's
not just opening the box he has set up
that's great you got to have kids uh
what do you call the thing that's like
the Intermediate for your sound system I
forget um you know what I'm talking
about right a receiver receiver yeah he
set up a receiver at my house yeah I did
you get something complicated you don't
even need help just invite Chris MCO
over and let make sure the box is in
sight hey come over for a loaf yeah a
loaf yeah whatever I know how they do in
brexit um oh I see so uh I you got to
help me set up my phone now yeah dude
invite him over all next week all right
so uh anyway right next
one Chris coming out of Texas my name is
Dylan got to talk fast cuz I'm at work
really quick love what you guys do keep
on doing it me through my days and it's
amazing check this out now I went to go
get a sandwich elaborate after this okay
I want you guys to talk about it what
the [__] why can't people make
sandwiches now I come a little bit out
of Italy myself Northern Italy my
grandfather came down we love sandwiches
that's just what it is yeah why can't
people make [__] decent sandwiches
you go buy a sandwich make it right make
it [__] right yeah so if you ever had
a [__] up sandwich please let's talk
about it cuz this is absolutely
ridiculous with these kids getting
getting hired and they they have no idea
how to make a sandwich it's sad yeah
love you guys working hard know you're
working hard too later thanks bro it's
true and it is weird every time I've
made my own sandwich I think
why is this as good as a sandwich that I
can get at a restaurant that's not how
it should be well wait what I'm saying I
make a sandwich and it's like that's
great good I don't know like what the
[__] I'm doing I'm just being like
that's probably good that's probably
good that's probably good and then I
bite it and I'm like but then I'll think
about like you know what like what he's
saying you go somewhere you buy a
sandwich and sometimes it's like this
isn't good enough to be a thing that is
sold at places oh nobody gives a [__]
about about their job yeah but well
obviously some sandwich places are the
[__] best yeah they care or they just
know what they're doing or keep an eye
on employees what he's saying and I
agree with something's going on
something's going on at some of these
places the seen an avatar at some of
these places where it's like what are we
doing why are you why are you even in
business as a place that sell weird H I
never really thought about that because
dude when I make a s no first of all no
and I'm telling you right now MH no
place can make a a better sandwich than
I can make myself well sure that's okay
know what you like I know it's person
thing but also if I make a sandwich for
anybody that ever came around uh they'd
go like this yo that was good really oh
yeah what's interesting about that is
I've never seen you make a sandwich for
you or anyone else because you're always
telling other people to do it yeah but
they know how I like
it that's basically you making it you
want me to make your a sandwich Kristen
dude I um you want make you a sand mom
yeah yeah sorry I stepped on it you
[__] it up I should let you do it but
um let me call my mom over uh so no uh
yeah I could make you a [__]
Bangarang sandwich cool that you would
be like and then next time you be like
oh yeah no make the sandwich really oh
yeah yeah yeah oh hey dude I'm telling
you the truth you're being weird about
it and it's making me thinking maybe
it's not the truth oh well then I'll
stop talking about it because it's true
oh okay now I believe you anybody
anytime time someone says I'll fine I'll
stop talking about it now they're being
completely honest and everything they've
already said is true just so everybody
understands that so listen so you can uh
yeah I that is actually I've never
really thought about that but that's a
good point it's actually so easy to make
a sandwich good it's it's probably the
easiest thing to make good that is of
some sort of sure yeah skill yeah it's
so easy it's it's really and you go to
like and yo like first of all
rest
like sandwiches at if you're a sandwich
place and you make a sandwich that's
less than an eight
mhm go out of business it's crazy
shutter the business yeah I agree yeah
shutter your business but there's places
like restaurants that have sandwiches
those are I would say not good 90% or
95% of the time because if you're at a
restaurant ordering a sandwich that
that's just not their thing that's not a
thing to get at a restaurant you know
I'm thinking yeah you get like a
dish sometimes there's like a French dip
or something at a fancy I guess good you
know but French dips are better at like
you know delies and [__]
yeah yeah I agree yeah the sandwich
place uh it's just Bonkers it's Bonkers
that place make a bad sandwich and it
happens so much like and places like
Quiznos that's what I was just going to
say [__] terrible dude and that's
what you do yeah oh man every sandwich
from Quiznos is Bonkers [__] I disagree
I think that about Subway though yeah no
no no no no no no Subway you can get a
good one you're God sometimes yeah
you're just so wrong it's nut rages dude
it is complete nut rage how wrong you
are
honestly Subway and quiz noes is bad
sure f i can get a thing I like at
Subway that's how I feel about quiz noes
that's it what do you get a quiz nose
the [__] barbecue [__] thing [__]
[__] dude you know what I hate more than
any other flavor is barbecue it's not
good oh really yeah oh everyone loves
barbecue no not me yeah oh nice dude I
like the kind of food barbecue like
almost the most but I don't prefer it I
love it love it what does that mean like
you don't like barbecue sauce yes yeah
that's what I mean that's what I mean or
like a a Mr what the [__] suie pen
question you couldn't deduce that well
well you said you said I don't
like Barb wait what did you
say a car a car a
car an absolute car a dying
bird um yeah I don't like barbecue
flavor is what I should say barbecue
flavor chips is a thing and that's
disgusting any kind of barbecue flavor
uh if you're making chicken on a
barbecue yeah okay but I don't want you
to do that brushing on it with the
barbecue sauce okay so you just don't
like barbecue sauce barbecue sauce so
think about
ribs like ribs chill no I don't like
ribs chill first of all here's the thing
about the ribs is dude I don't want to
be come out looking like I was in World
War II after I eat Chili's baby back
ribs there I did it but dude I don't
want do the barbecue sauce part that's
the whole reason you were doing it no no
no no no I already did the barbecue
sauce all together nah that's like a
theater dor I just did parts of it as I
wanted to do it but I don't want to dude
it's oh [__] it's so so annoying eating
[__] ribs dude it really is it's like
dude first of all it comes out it looks
like a dead body it's it's half of a
[__] being and you're sitting here
you got to break it off it's all over
it's it's like you get it here you know
what I mean and then like and then
afterwards the worst part is when they
give you the [__] the wet na [__]
enough yeah it it it's it's this big
it's enough for one and a half fingers
it's this big it's the size of Anthony's
penis and I got to use it all over dude
and it suck you know what the worst is
giving someone a wet nap this [__]
drives me nuts uhoh when somebody gives
you a wet nap when they haven't it's the
first thing they give you when you at an
airplane when you sit down and they're
like mhm for what dude for what this is
you're acting like you're doing me a
nicity to get clean hands before you eat
is why they do it not so you can save it
for later [__] [__] that dude who
because I'm chilling okay say no I do
okay I no I don't want that well why are
you so confrontational about it's not
their idea it's just like part of their
job you know they didn't think like that
guy looks like he wants a wet now they
like this they like this to the person
next to me the guy always takes it it's
so Cuda to take that [__] it really is
man and they just take it and then they
go before before they even go down say
you don't need to I'm not I don't want
one when the guy takes it you should say
get real close to him say why did you
take that like confrontation I'm going
to next time lean over and point at him
next time I'm going to ask him why did
you take that and if he says I wanted it
I say no no
no uh oh why why did you want it break
this down for me please he's going to be
he's going to be thinking God we got
four and a half more hours in this yeah
dude especially when I'm on my way to
Orlando that's a long flight my baby
well you know what's weird is when yeah
they give it to you and then people
[__] are put it on their face yeah
dude what's that what the [__] dude I
only wipe my ass with it but I don't I
play what
else like lifting the arm thing so you
get closer yeah yeah yeah yeah sir sir
sir sir
like in your face they he they hear you
go here you
go
dude [__] planes are too they Jam
back people in so tight dude you're just
like this with your the person next to
you yeah yeah dude
yeah they got the nerve to be like they
got the nerve like the nerve the [__]
G the sack to be like can you lift your
chair up we got land dude are
you like that's the difference of me
getting beheaded if we crash you know
what's my [__] favorite thing
theyes do now is they try to shame your
ass for having the exact number of
carry-ons that they tell you you can
have when you buy your ticket they're
like their flight's really full so if
anybody's willing to check their bags
that they have on cuz you know if
there's no room you're going to have to
check them anyway so you might as well
do it now it's like no I'm playing by
the rules I'm [__] doing exactly what
I'm supposed to do airlines are so
shitty bro do it better cut out 10 seats
even four and just make a little more
room for people [__] bags dude they
go they they they the last plane I was
on they said we can't take off I swear
to God we still need 16 more people to
check bags dude what
16 it's that's such a shitty policy dude
like what you can't do the thing like
you can't say everyone gets two bags and
then if a fight's full and everyone has
two bags there's no possible way you can
fit all the bag that's a shitty policy
how about this don't bring the [__]
wet naaps and fit another bag right just
leave all the wet naps
behind no wet nap left behind all right
let's get in another one no wet naap
Left
Behind hello Chris and Matt it's Sophia
all the way from Mexico and I need help
with a coworker so he's the it manager
he's probably 45 years old and he's very
kind but he's creepy there's something
weird about him and I'm 27 years old and
every time he sees me he takes a photo
of me and I don't want him taking photos
of me and for example I'll be very
focused at a meeting and he will take a
photo he will send it through whatap and
he'll be like why so serious or I'll be
Printing and he'll take a photo or I
will be with more people and He will
take the photo but it's very obvious
that I am the focus I am in the middle
of that shot and I really don't want him
taking photos of me and I don't know
what to do what if I go to HR and they
fire him and his three daughters suffer
from this or what if they don't fire him
and he'll be like but I send the photos
to her because that's why I I think he
sends them to me or they don't fire him
and then Things become very weird and
uport every time we have to work
together so I don't know maybe there's
something like a funny comeback I can
tell him or I don't know please help me
out what I should do or am I just
exaggerating and it's not that bad
because I've asked around thinking this
was like his way of being funny and he
doesn't take photos of anyone else it's
just of me so I don't know what should I
do I mean hat to break it to you but
whether he realizes it or not he is
flirting with you and that frankly
[__] sucks for you did I'm sorry I
missed did she say it's her boss
cooworker a cooworker not her boss she
said cooworker I think did she say
cooworker in the beginning yeah because
that's a big difference if it's a
coworker ask just straight up say why do
you always take pictures of me that
makes me really uncomfortable and I
don't want I you don't have to say I
don't want it but just like ask the best
put him on his own heels because frankly
taking a picture of someone frequently
without their consent or even like
knowledge that you might be doing so is
putting them back on their heels so he
it's like you're kind of just like yeah
true it's like he can't not expect that
that's [__] [__] dude I'm so wary of
even getting someone in the background
of a photo that I'm taking if it's all
people I know and like we're all in a
public setting and like
I anybody who's in a picture that I
might be taking I want them to know or
at least have signaled to me that it's
okay for me to do that that's he's
trying to [__] flirt with you and
that is the worst way to do it yeah yeah
he is he is yeah he likes you which is
so annoying annoying because it's at
work but yeah I I would I think I mean
in America that would be the guy would
go to like you know prison for nine
years but I think that you I think that
you should start by saying something to
him yes yeah for sure I going directly
to HR is like it may not be necessary
you don't want them to get fired if if
CU maybe it's hey dude it makes you
uncomfortable when you take pictures of
me and then he says oh my gosh I'm so
sorry and never does it again exactly
you know what I'm saying it's totally
possible he doesn't real obviously it's
possible he doesn't realize he's making
you uncomfortable I mean he could be bad
at reading signs he could be like oh
this girl likes me I mean he could be
like completely yeah and if sometimes
all it takes is yo don't do that and
then people are like oh okay then
especially because it's at work he's not
going to want to get fired or get
reported at for sure true that's why I
was like is it boss or cooworker if it's
boss it's a whole different thing it's
way stickier and sucks way more true uh
but if it's a co-worker yeah absolutely
just bring it up with them directly and
be like even if you you don't have to
ask cuz honestly who cares what the
answer is just tell them true I I'm not
really comfortable having my picture
taken uh if you don't mind not taking my
picture and then he does anything in
retaliation then you definitely go to as
of course absolutely yeah but you know
it's possible because he's already the
kind of guy that's taking pictures of
you without your consent he might do
something like oh I'm sorry oh in
America he would do that but in she's in
Mexico so it might be like you're the
daughter of a motherless goat you know
what I mean like yeah but I'm not making
but that's in Mex Mexico they do crazy
[__] like that okay like honor like it's
you're a motherless goat okay well in
any case he might say something
defensive whatever he says even if it
[__] is total [__] [__] just
like Let It Go by because the point the
point is you want him to stop taking
your picture that's all that matters he
can be as defensive as as childish as he
wants in response all you need to do is
convey that you don't want that to
happen anymore and just so you know that
is not rude of you at all no it's not
rude yeah that is not even remotely rude
in any way it's a boundary I guess yeah
yeah well
wow you know uh that sucks dude God that
sucks yeah we've got a few things like
that this is why dudes are dudes are
annoying you know so true guys at work
guys at the workplace stop stop and the
gym stop it just stop it guys are just
kind of annoying in that way yeah it's
really weird man and then they get
bunched up too when they they get all
bald up dude when when you when you
approach them about it sometimes so be
prepared but that God man I don't envy
that with women that that that's that's
so annoying because as a man you be like
yo bro but as a woman you have to worry
about well maybe he'll stab me a number
of things Beyond even Beyond even actual
violence there's a number of things to
worry about it's totally sucks yeah all
right want to do next one I take
pictures of Anthony all the time Chris
you're my heart you get me Matt you're a
wise wonderful soul I love you guys so
much um so I've been living on the
Jersey Shore for the past like four
years and I go for walks on the
boardwalk a lot and I see the same man
every time like for four years and every
time he walks by me he's so chipper and
kind and he gives me a good morning like
says it the same exact way every time
and just recently it's been starting to
bug me oh and I'm like that's probably
like so rude and so deeper but today I
just decided I'm going to beat him to it
so I saw him walking from a distance and
I yelled over like hey good morning and
it just made me giggle and I was like
thinking about the whole idea of like
saying hi to strangers and I'm a
recovering people pleaser so I feel like
I used to always think like I had to
smile back and like say hi or like give
some someone to smile and be kind and
like I know there's value to that but at
the same time I'm in my 30s now I'm
tired I'm like I don't feel like wasting
my energy on like faking a smile to a
stranger but then if I don't am I like
so rude God that's weird I just want to
see what you guys thought of that the
whole thing is actually so benign but
also deeply rooted
in pleasing people wow here's the here's
the problem with all of it and there's
only
one you're thinking about it too much
full stop the end whether you smile or
not a good one does not matter whether
you smile back or not does not matter it
probably doesn't and I'll tell you why
it doesn't matter even if someone Smiles
at you and you don't smile back even if
which they're not going to but I'm maybe
in some cases someone will be like what
an [__] within three seconds not only
will that person forget about the
interaction they will completely forget
that you exist when we're worrying so
much about this people pleasing because
I do it too so I can relate but we're
what we're also what we're actually
doing is elevating in our own minds our
sense of how much we actually matter to
people we don't matter at all to
strangers they don't give a [__] about
us not really they want us in general
like wellbeing they care about but they
don't specifically care about us as
individuals so after they've passed us
and we're no longer in their line of
sight they're not thinking about us
whether you were rude or not and by the
way it's not rude to just not smile it's
not rude to just it's only rude to be
rude so if you're not being rude they're
not going to remember you good morning
[__] you yeah that would be rude that
would count you know they might remember
you in case you did if you did
that isn't that interesting though yeah
it's interesting yeah
like so you know
sometimes people will come up and
say you know that they're like either a
fan or like something to me like or just
hey you
know and I'm always
like I'm I'm I'm always appreciative
always and but then sometimes I'm like
different levels of in a good mood of
course you know and occasionally I walk
away and I
think I hope I was enough nice enough
that to where they don't think I'm a
dick and I didn't ruin it for them like
the idea of me mhm you know I I I think
about that sometimes and I'm
like it's so weird because I
don't
I I genuinely am appreciative whenever
somebody comes up to me and says
something nice but also
like I don't owe them anything and and
as like a like a person even like not I
don't mean as like someone's a fan like
you don't really owe somebody a stranger
any of your time you know no you
don't but if she were to just not say
[__] I mean 95% of people would think
she's an
[__] if he said you know what I'm
saying more than that if she if he
walked by her and said good morning and
she didn't do anything yeah she said
something that I personally disagree
with she called it a or implied with so
many words that it's a waste of her
energy to smile back or I don't feel
like that is an expenditure of my energy
to the point that I'm like going to miss
that energy throughout the course of the
day if somebody Smiles at me I will I
will I will always smile back too and I
will do so because that actually makes
me feel good I like walking by a
stranger having like a really brief non
interaction with them just exchanging
some kind of vague nicity because I like
believing that people in the world
generally in like a vague broad overview
way care about other people I feel that
way and I it's it makes me feel good
when I'm led to believe other people
feel that way as well that's just me
though I don't know I guess I guess yeah
if I say good morning to someone that
I'm walking by like a neighbor and they
just keep their face straight and keep
walking I'll definitely think what a
[__] [__] some yeah yeah I guess
but also sometimes it's more it takes
more energy to not do the thing for me
at least right well that's kind of what
she's lying I mean you're she's putting
so much mental effort into this she's
thinking about it too much full stop
you're right it's almost like you'll
what you're saying is you it'll be it's
less energy ultimately to just say it
back because then it's like you're
thinking about it yeah that's good so
just save yourself the energy of having
to like recap it and go over it over and
over again and just do it yeah just say
good morning yeah think about it as a
exercise for yourself you're doing it
cuz saving yourself further down I was
going to say that because this and I was
going to say this in the beginning of
one when she started talking this is the
thing I thought of is that you this all
this says more about you than it does
about him anyway oh yeah so yeah 100%
back to that in my head but yeah that's
uh yeah so just say it so yeah do the
thing that's going to require the least
amount of energy and that thing
counterintuitively is doing it back
leaving it where you find it and then
just going about your life and not
thinking about it
anymore how interesting and you know
what it's just like okay no that's the
worst point no I I mean you'll see next
one okay what's good Matt what's good
Chris I have a question for you guys
I'll get right to it last time I was in
a really long-term relationship it
lasted for 10 years I lived with my ex
for about nine of those
years um stayed single for you know
maybe 3 months before I hopped back into
another like long-term relationship I'm
32 years old he's 31 years old and both
of our leases are up and we've decided
to take the jump and move in together
it's the most mature relationship I've
ever been in and so I'm not like too
worried about compatibility and we've
been together long enough that we know
how each other kind of lives like how he
does the dishes the cleanliness Factor
like compatible on all
fronts my issue lies with those three
months that I was single I very much for
the first time in my life learned to
enjoy me time and I'm finding myself
already get getting irritable with like
the littlest things little ticks that
normally wouldn't bother anybody and
normally wouldn't bother me and I find
myself worried about if we live together
not having enough personal
space how would you go about dealing
with that thanks so much love you guys
and Chris sorry you had such a bizarre
time in Montreal cheers oh oh she's
talking about cuz I um got hackled but
it wasn't it was nothing was bizar yeah
that's sweet of you to say thank you I
knew she was Canadian do you
know uh yeah yeah
I I I think two things about this you
want to go first you go
first um
I I think here's this is not really an
answer to a question but it it's my
takeaway you feel those things that
waiting to move in is not going to make
those things yeah
what I'm saying is if you want to be
with this person for a long time you're
going to have to deal with this at some
point at some point you are going to
live together so might as well do it and
see how it plays out and if it becomes
an issue create and he'll he'll
understand this if he's a good partner
if you say like look I really uh am
realizing how much I value and kind of
need alone time
and moving forward I would like to you
know fit that into our life together
that can mean me leaving it can mean you
leaving home for whatever it is you know
like but you know I think it's important
for our overall health as a couple for
me to have aone time he will absolutely
understand yeah I think uh I I think you
know I don't know I mean people make it
work it's tough to do like 10 years in a
relationship and then jump back into
another one it's like somebody might be
like well then how do you even know who
you really are if You' never been alone
and stuff but it's
like that whole
being uh alone thing that whole having
time to yourself and wanting that I
don't think that ever goes away like
you're not going to like just because
you do for like say five years go by and
you don't live with him and then you
think okay I got it all out of my system
like that's just not how it works you're
not going to get it out of your system I
think you're just growing up you're 32
now and other things are important to
you and maybe this relationship the
first one ending was a catalyst to
change right and and that's how you
realized it um also 20 to 30 oh my God I
know I know I know I know yeah cuz when
you're 22 you don't want aone time you
just want to be with everybody and when
you're 32 you want aone time when you're
22 you don't [__] know any [__] thing
in the whole [__] world when you're 32
you know some Dennis finina [__]
things yeah right so yeah I think that
it's more about growing up and less
about having your uhoh am I missing out
on something I think that you're just
realizing who you are through the midst
of what's happening in your life um
really this other dude if he's worth any
weight if you just say like yo I'm
realizing in my last relationship I
didn't have me time I need to have me
time and he's anything other than like
oh okay yeah he should want that you I
mean maybe it's like I If someone said
that to me I might in the beginning be a
little insecure about it like why
doesn't she want to spend all her time
with me but like then the next thought
is oh wait I'm an adult she's an adult
she's telling me what she needs okay
great not me if someone said that to me
early on or that you about immediately
propose marriage to them because I want
I want to be alone too I I need a lot of
alone
time yes exactly yeah and then separate
for a few days to have aone time and
then go on marry me in 6
years um yeah that's that's uh good you
know we do a lot of silly stuff on this
podcast but when we buckle down we
really can give people some good advice
yeah ESP especially me especially me I
was just going to say should we do one
more sure give the people what they want
a model a mug
shot big fan of both of you uh quick
question today growing your hair out you
both have have longer hair I'm growing
it out from a buzz cut I look better
with hair my wife thinks I look better
with hair okay um I'm just not patient
and I keep buzzing it off because it's
one of my quirks with dealing with OCD
hit s deeper but uh yeah any advice for
growing it out thanks I mean you look
good I only know you would like this
yeah he looks good but he's saying he
want then just [__] wait it out bro
dude yeah you gotta just your wife likes
it better too bro that's the thing when
you get the urge to cut it just remind
yourself but my wife likes it better
when my hair is here and that's my wife
and I want her to like my hair also he
likes it better he said right but I'm
saying if obviously his own willpower is
not
allowing to I'm saying let it be about
her uh put it about her and maybe you'll
have a little bit more uh courage to
wait it out dude cuz cuz right now you
[__] you're pussing out every time you
go to buzz your hair go back and play
this
clip don't be a [__] little wussy
baby Man Okay okay right don't be a
[__] little wussy baby man just let
your hair grow or every time you go look
in the mirror in your eyes and say I'm a
wuss you know cuz that's wuss Behavior
dude and I'm not for that man yeah
you're a little wussy baby man you know
what you know what you're doing uh you
you're keeping it you're keeping it real
dry for your wife man are you or are you
not a little wussy baby man right yeah
it's honestly comes down to it's it's
simple as that it's as simple as that if
you buzz your hair before it gets long
again you're a little Wy baby man a
little wussy baby man and you need
diapers yep you need diapers and you
need little toys that are made out of
whatever material that you can bite so
that you don't swallow it get one of
those things that you tie around like
this yep and yeah yeah yeah yeah P get a
pacifier because you are a little we'll
see [__] baby yeah okay and and sit
down on your bottom and with your legs
out and sometimes fall over yeah yeah
and don't use your hands to stop your
fall right yeah yeah hit your head and
then cry hit your chin and cry and bite
your lip have too much blood come out
because yeah and yeah [__] and then also
in your diaper and then uh spit out only
milk yeah you're a baby yeah you are a
little wussy baby man and these are the
things that you should be doing instead
of sleep in a crib yeah honestly get a
crib and you might have kids if you have
kids take them out yep because they're
older than you you get in the crib and
because now you are the baby and that's
who you are now sweetheart hey um I'm
cutting my hair good night I'm getting
in the crib yeah yep will you but will
you put me in there yeah and qu change
me yeah get me a changing
table just like like this she
you you put diaper just because you you
cut your hair cuz you're a wuss you're a
little wussy baby so there you go man
don't don't be a little wussy baby man
and your hair will grow and everything
will be fine we believe in you man yeah
you can do it all right
uh uh so that's it appreciate you my
special grow or die is out now go to
chia.com and check out the special it's
Sunday what else you going to do dude
watch it um go to theprivate record.com
and submit yourself as a guest for my
new podcast the private record yeah and
then other than that I will be in
Baltimore Trenton Philadelphia and
reading pre love
you bye
bye-bye broke
it
hello
hello hello